my guess is the newest regular on kill
tony good friend of mine a guy from
seattle i'm excited to welcome the very
funny hans kim
hey what's up adam good to see you again
yeah man thanks for coming on are you
recording you're in your van right now
yeah
nice nice
are you in the back of the front
um i'm in the living quarters
we get a lot i i have a lot of [ __ ]
questions for you because
before this episode i was thinking like
did we see each other like
a year ago last year
was that when you were up in seattle was
it two years ago now
no it's during the pandemic
okay i visited during
the normal years a couple times but i
think we met during the pandemic
yeah it i had heard about you quite a
bit
and then we hung out a little bit but
you were only here for a minute but
you started in seattle right like you
that's where you started doing comedy
yeah that's my alma mater yeah and
do you miss it
yeah it was a great place i enjoyed it
you know
low pressure no industry
um i could do as many mics as i wanted
and i could do 10 minutes 15 minutes at
a music open
mic um
the people there were
nice and smart and not like too
career focused
but like also like funny and stuff
yeah it was a great place to start but
like you ended up going to new york but
what were you doing
nine to five prior to going to new york
i was just living at my mom's house my
parents house
and i didn't really have to work i got a
job at burger master for like three
months i
did uber eats whenever i needed money
but i
had food i had food stamps so i didn't
really need to money for food and i had
rent so i had food and all i needed
money for was gas to get around the mics
but yeah i was just living the comedy
life full full time from day one you
know i didn't tell myself i needed a
nine to five to define myself because uh
i don't
so i just i didn't have a job
but didn't you you went to like [ __ ]
georgia tech didn't you
hello yeah yeah uh i went to georgia
tech i did work at a startup company for
six months
uh right after college in chattanooga so
actually i was in college in atlanta i
got suspended for one semester for
shoplifting so it took four and a half
years
to graduate and then
oh like i was just stealing a bunch of
stuff all the time but the time i got
caught was like
plates and bowls and computer mice and
just anything i could fit in my bag and
walk out with anything i wanted it's
like shopping as a rich person it's
pretty cool
but yeah i got caught and it
cost a lot of money to pay for a lawyer
actually my lawyer who defended who got
me like pre-trial aversion is the same
guy that's defending in atlanta right
now the murderer of ahmad arbury the
black guy that got shot while jogging
jason sheffield was my lawyer against
shoplifting and defending
mcmichaels travis mcmichaels for
shooting a black dude for running so
that's the kind of guy that
takes your money and
makes sure you don't have to see jail
time if you have enough money in georgia
dude the coincidences that you have in
your life and just like what you've run
into i
it
like we're gonna get to where you're at
right now but i've been i mean i've been
meaning to talk to you for a while now
like this whole like
decision to just go full-time comedy
live in a van
give zero [ __ ] like you went from
seattle to living in new york and
like how did that work because it's
your experience was different than a lot
of people like
you
you weren't really working when you were
there right
yeah i mean i started out working at
cerret metalworks
which is like a metal working company
they make spiral stereo cases and stuff
so i was working when i first got there
i was living in sunset park and
i was doing like two three mics today
and traveling 40 minutes to go home and
get to mike's and stuff
um
yeah so i i was staying on my friend's
couch when i first moved looking for a
job and then i got a place to rent
uh near my job just cheap in sunset park
which is like far away it's like in
south brooklyn where the poor people
live none of the art happens there
but um
yeah i had a job and then i eventually
was like i don't want to work that much
it just takes away from what i actually
want to do and it doesn't give me
anything besides like you know social
credit
so i just quit and i bought a minivan
for 700 bucks and started living in the
back of a minivan in january in new york
city in a sleeping bag
it was fun
i stayed in that thing for a year
learned about myself and
survival and
thermodynamics and heat transfer
um yeah like keeping yourself warm was a
fun exciting challenge and it's just
like going back to the basics like it
costs too much to have someone else
build my home for me i'll just build my
own home so
i did that and then i was free to do
comedy i lived in right by the creek in
queens creek in the cave and i just did
mike sir they have three mics there
every every night pretty much
so i would just do the free mics in new
york and
slowly get better and
be around some of the
most talented most curmudgeonly
depressed
[ __ ] in the in the world for comedy
so that made me a lot better i think but
i don't want to be there too long
because then i would be depressed and
uh sad and just like what the [ __ ]
am i doing here no one respects
anything but
success and
money grubbing and shaking the right
hands and all that [ __ ] so
i'm glad i got out but uh i did it did
help me improve i think it was a great
experience
did
you didn't [ __ ] with the clubs at all
right
yeah i mean it's not by choice they
didn't [ __ ] with me um i would have
loved to have done some comedy clubs but
uh yeah i
uh i tried a couple shows at new york
comedy club i went up once or twice at
gotham
uh but yeah they don't really care they
have enough funny people they're not
trying to
get a funnier show
they're just trying to maintain and
sell hot dogs and beers they don't
really care
to sell the chicken wings
finding the newest talent
yeah
it um wilfred talked to me when he was
in town and he mentioned like because
i'm i'm interested in going to new york
but
he said to me he's like dude this it
what new york used to be for comedy like
the development
aspect of it isn't there anymore like
there's no infrastructure where clubs
like lift you up and and like there's no
like ladder system to helping people get
better it's just like them
selling tickets and doing shows and
stuff would you agree with that or
[Music]
yeah i mean i think so unless you're one
of the few people that get lucky and
happen to
get into the system i mean they don't
uh
i think it's our culture like all they
care about is money but
um you know if you do get lucky it's
awesome it's just not very likely
in terms of the odds but the best part
of it is just getting to be around other
people like yourself
and the people
make it good the clubs don't the people
do
yeah my
i just met uh i think a friend of yours
nasil azeal
i don't know if you remember her from
new york
oh
yeah um
i forgot how to pronounce her name yeah
how did you say it neces i [ __ ] it up
she's super cool and you can just see
like the new york on her that she like
you know
grinded and like just loves comedy like
i think it's to start there is a [ __ ]
it seems
i mean i'm i'm happy that i've gotten in
front of the audiences that i have in
seattle i just yeah i i mean
if would you do
what you did over again like would you
go to new york from seattle or would you
go somewhere else possibly
i mean this was pre-pandemic so yeah
what what other options are there i
could just go to another middling city
and
not get any success or i could not get
any success in new york with a small
chance that i might have success
and also get a lot better because just
being around that many talented people
is great but
um
i feel like if you stay in new york too
long or if you're the wrong type of
person
then you're intimidated by all the
talent around you and you
don't work on your own talent you just
try to make it by cheating or
you know getting lucky so then you just
turn it into this like businessman kind
of comedian
and uh you don't work on your
personality you just become a husk of a
person
just trying to
climb the ladder
and i think that's a danger of being in
new york too long as long as you are
happy enough and creative enough to
actually
pursue your scale then i think you
should be in new york to get better and
then
hopefully you can get successful there
or you can move to another city
and start working the road or something
what so you went from the minivan
in new york to like this full-size
sprinter you got like what was the
rationale for that was just
like was it not working in the minivan
when you were there
i mean the minivan would die all the
time and it was not drivable i couldn't
do anything with it so i was like i need
to get a new
and if i'm going to spend
fifteen hundred dollars on a new minivan
it's gonna break down in a couple years
so i might as well get like a nice one
and take care of it and stay in it a
long time so it's just like if i'm gonna
get something new anyways i might as
well get something nice
yeah
and you
you got the sprinter van did you like
outfit or because you did all that [ __ ]
like on the street of new york right
like it's not like you had a
garage to take all this like people with
van life people usually like take their
[ __ ] in and work on it for six months
weren't you like kind of living in it
while you were working on it
yeah i would go to parking lots home
depot parking lots just buy all this
stuff there then work on it and then i'd
be like oh [ __ ] i forgot this thing and
then i could just go into home depot and
buy supplies
so it's pretty convenient
so yeah people would look at me weird i
would take those shopping carts and set
them up like little work benches and
start cutting
panels and wood so i just used the
things around me
yes just slowly little by little built
uh my friend helped me built the bed i
got this kitchen
kitchen island
that i use as my sink i cut a hole in
the kitchen island as my sink
i got in coney island for free
because like having a van you can just
pick up a lot of bulky items that people
want to get rid of
uh so that was convenient
like
after
after doing this would you are you happy
with the choice to do because that's a
big [ __ ] investment to go from still
living in it it's three years later
still in this thing
you paid 12 grand so it's pretty solid
yeah
it's like a year's worth of rent
yeah and
you've been super mobile right like you
even before the pandemic you went all
the way down to florida and [ __ ]
and yeah
like you've been using it just to like
travel for comedy on the cheap right
i think
you cut out there for a second
yeah so i was in miami when the pandemic
hit and i was like i'm not going back to
new york because in march of 2020 new
york was
crazy with coronavirus and now i don't
have to like go back and you know close
out my apartment and get all my stuff
and move out i just have everything with
me like
i uh i was very mobile and so i just
took off because i was doing this like
two months two month road trip down the
coast i did philadelphia washington dc
richmond atlanta and then i was in miami
so
i was on the run i was i was mobile when
the pandemic hit and now i can be
you know i can move anywhere i want
all right
better being in the van
like outside of cities like do you like
it more
because i would think like parking and
[ __ ] like that it would just be louder
in new york and
like
you're in texas now right
uh yeah i mean it's good and bad because
uh new york like
people mind their own business and
uh you know there's like lots of cars
and
uh and you can take the subway so you
can just leave the car parked the van
parked and go anywhere you want without
having to use miles
and then out and anywhere else in
america suburban sprawl so you have to
drive everywhere so you have to actually
you use your van
to drive around um
[Music]
uh new york was
pretty tough because it's like dirty and
stuff like that but it wasn't too bad i
mean all cities are pretty much the same
right now i'm in the suburbs i'm plugged
into power that's pretty useful
um but yeah i mean really depends and
plus the benefits of new york are pretty
awesome like new york is a pretty
awesome
city um but yeah i mean
the best is just out in the country when
no one gives a [ __ ] or when no one is
like i went camping during the pandemic
and it was just
it's ideal because you can just
fling all the doors open and
you don't have to worry about someone
peering in so yeah yeah you were weren't
you in the [ __ ] middle of the desert
for like
a while right
yeah it's pretty dope
it's great everything i need in here
like i have solar panels
like i don't need the city
uh i can just go wherever i want i would
just go on hikes i'd build fires
cook me i have a fridge in here i would
bring me i could survive for
at least two weeks
i had water
i have a sink
uh
i have a tv i was watching a lot of like
political podcasts and stuff while the
capital riots were happening and trump
was getting
uh you know doing his thing
so it's just like
awesome like i have everything i need in
here and it it's a great feeling when
you don't need things from other people
yeah it's it's crazy that you're coming
on because i the last episode i did was
with my
uh cousin and he was he lived in
northern
alaska for
like eight years
in the woods like with nothing he's on
the show life below zero and i'm your
cousin yeah glenn is his name oh via
navoo uh
we went up and stayed at his camp
and i talked to him about you doing the
van and thing i'm because i've been
considering it too
but
i
i what what are the downsides dude like
tell me just be honest like is because
every time i think about this i'm like i
don't want [ __ ] in the van like that
that aspect of it is
like it are are there some parts of it
that are still like
just unsavored to you to where like
you're like uh this is
a bummer of this or
is there nothing
i [ __ ] in the van i piss in the van i
got a piss bucket right here um
i have sex in the van
i uh
sometimes it leaks i have to plug it up
but you know that's it's not really a
big deal i'd much rather do that than
like show up to an office and [ __ ]
pretend to be dedicated to the company
ethos
um
i think that the social
spiritual cost of living and having a
home off the free market is way higher
than [ __ ] in a van
like a shading in a van is like
it's understandable but like wasting
your life 40 hours a week for some
[ __ ]
companies uh not understandable that's a
waste of your life
everyone has to [ __ ] i just happen to do
it in a bucket not everyone has to waste
all their time in a
pointless company but uh i mean yeah i
mean people are some people are good at
that so if you're good at wasting your
time and pretending to care about things
that no one could possibly care about i
would say continue to
work in an office
yeah i
no i don't like it dude i don't like it
at all and that's why i just i i do the
like math on the situation and
i
i always think about like i mean the
change that you made that's a big
[ __ ] change to make like was there
was there a specific thing that
got you to make that decision or do kind
of the leap of faith like
because it is a little
outside of social
norms just be like okay yeah this is
what i'm gonna do and i'm gonna sleep in
this [ __ ] van and
i mean was there someone that inspired
you to do it or was it just like it made
sense
yeah it was more of a practical thing it
wasn't like
uh angry or like a you know spur of the
moment you know thing it was just like
i was so used to not paying rent with my
mom
looking at my mom's house for five years
in seattle i was like why why am i doing
this this is a waste of time
how can i not do this how can i not pay
rent and then this seemed like an option
uh and now i own
i own this thing i own my own means of
producing my survival so now i don't
have to rely on others
um but yeah i mean it was like it was it
was like practical it was just like i
don't want to work what can i do and
this was like
one of the only options unless i want to
get a tent and sleep on the sidewalk
i mean it [ __ ] makes sense and it's
it's
i mean arguably
having that has
led to so much of what you've been going
through recently like because you were
up in seattle during the pandemic
that's when i met you
and then you ended up taking the van
down
like down the coast to l.a and [ __ ] and
then
you were in the desert for a while and
then you got to texas right
yeah okay i was multiple
and
what was the
like what was the rationale behind that
why did you want to go to texas
joe rogan and tony hinchcliffe were here
they were
making everyone
come here as like a beacon it's like
we're gonna do comedy here
um so it was very
awesome like and i was already
disillusioned with the centers of power
after being in new york i was like oh
this isn't
what it is meant to be this is just a
money grab and it's just a way to
exploit people
so i was just like i don't care about la
or new york anymore i know
it's not about comedy for them it's
about uh i don't know financial solvency
so i i was like oh let's just go to
austin
uh because they're starting a new scene
and also i was it was a toss-up because
i really enjoyed my time in la like i
felt like i was making headway there so
i was like i could go to la or i could
go to austin i already been to l.a let
me go to austin i haven't been and my
friend rebecca peterson really helped me
she was like yeah you should go to
austin austin sounds dope cause i was
like living with her
for like a month or two just hanging out
um
on a property because she has like a
rental property where she rents out rvs
to but
um yeah she was uh she was just like
yeah that sounds awesome you should go
there so i was like yeah i'll go there
maybe i'll get to meet joe rogan
um and then i did so it all worked out
i feel like you're gonna end up on his
podcast
like i i really think that you're gonna
end up on his podcast at some point
listen
wasn't glenn on his part he was yeah
yeah that's where i saw him i actually i
talked to him about that and
he
he
he asked rogan like how he came up with
this material and
they didn't really know each other he
was like walking into the studio and
rogan's like i just smoke a lot of pot
but
yeah man it
it just what is austin like right now
like it seems
so
because wasn't austin like a super
liberal scene comedy wise
yeah prior to all of this
it was like seattle
yeah
and what is happening
now it's like a bunch of
you know joe rogan fans a bunch of young
dudes
who say [ __ ] move there and [ __ ]
and now it's like completely different
there's two scenes there's the people
who just moved here and the people that
are the old scene and they're almost
like completely severed from each other
um but like the new scene is like very
vibrant people are very excited to be
here
and they're most of them are like two or
three years in but they're so
enthusiastic and they love comedy and
i don't know it's a great energy
everyone's really excited to be here and
everyone's like driving each other to
succeed and
no one is like
zero-sum mentality everyone is like you
know positive and generally
as much as comedians can be um so it's a
great energy like this is we're making
it
uh our own and we don't rely
we're not relying on the way things used
to be to tell us how to be this we're
just being
uh we're just making it as we go and
it's exciting like uh
it's it's a great scene it's a great
energy this is like a once in a lifetime
opportunity to be a part of something
like this
so i think it's great
what do you i mean what are you doing
most of the time though aren't you just
like
playing katan and [ __ ] like i i
i
have
seen some of your sets on uh kill tony
like it seems like a big ass party down
there all the time like it's a party
yeah everyone's partying we all hang out
we all drink like
yeah it's crazy like most of the time it
doesn't happen
most of the time like in the comedy
world you do your set everyone has jobs
they go home but now like not a lot of
people have jobs i guess
and we just go over to whoever is
partying
and we just hang out and drink and talk
[ __ ] and
smoke weed and do a lot of drugs there's
like ketamine here molly i did two
nights ago there's dmt pens i have
um you know there's a lot a lot of drugs
here mushrooms and acid of course
and everyone is having a good time i
think the pandemic was really like oh we
we uh only have one life
and it can all be taken away and
having other people around is a very
good thing and
because we were social distancing for
two or three months
some longer
and it's like we were invigorated uh
with our love of society and humanity
and friendship again so
i think everyone is just expressing that
and everyone's hanging out and having a
good time together
that's [ __ ] wild so then how did uh
did were you on kill tony
when it was in
la still or did you start
like getting up there
in texas
that's when i
really started doing it so are you
cunning you cut out there for a little
bit i started doing it in austin yeah it
all started here in texas
and why did you like what was appealing
about it
because
kill tony yeah because
this is the thing like you you're
someone who's very
um
kind of
is it fair to say anti-industry like
you're not
you're not looking to really like
monetize your comedy
unless it's on your terms
yeah
and
there's a lot of people that would go on
kill tony
for the opposite reason like they want
to get
notoriety and fame and stuff and you've
always been somebody like there's
there's not a lot of people i know that
would go to like 20
30 open mics in a week
because that's what they want to be
doing like
why was it why did you whine do kill
tony what what about that uh situation
was appealing to you
um
i like killed tony because it gives
comedians a chance to do comedy and on a
big scale
and in the interview section
it's about like who the person is and
finding interesting things about them
and it's just like a real
people and doing open mics for
eight years it's like you get to
get in that mindset of like oh how do
you talk to people what is interesting
about them
what does this person want
just perfect for that sort of mentality
for that for being in that kind of uh
you know environment so
it just fit like i was like i'm in that
sort of mind state as it is
being doing open mics and kill tony and
bodies that kind of mindset on a
professional grand scale
so it was a kill tony's great um i
wouldn't
think it's like industry i don't think
it's for
uh
you know i think it's more uh
and you know like it's just tony he made
it on his own so
it was it's like a real show like the
show that came from the bottom and now
it's here
for sure
yeah it
what are your thoughts on i mean you've
you've done
probably more open mic than anybody i
know
and
there are a lot of people i know that
would be like you have to get in front
of real audiences in order to get better
or stronger like what's your opinion on
that
i think that they overestimate
the
value of dumb country hicks in walla
walla
who are
not cultured and just want cheap
emotions
and they
underestimate the value of disgruntled
grumpy comedians sitting in a dark room
waiting to go up those are real audience
members too that's an audience of people
human beings with ears that hear your
joke and also happen to know comedy on a
deeper level than
some [ __ ] dude who pays 40 bucks to
watch comedy once a year
and if you can make that audience
laugh
then you can find that skill to transfer
over to another audience
and
i think that
you deal with the audience that you have
and if this is the only audience
available to me then i will perfect my
skill on them and then i will use
whatever transferable skills
to
talk to
dumb
low iq yokels in the middle of the
country it's easier to do that
transition than the other way around
i think you're right
yeah it's
i don't know it's it's [ __ ] hard in
seattle too like there's just not as
much opportunity to get up like
everything's so sporadic and stuff so
i'm thinking about personally like what
what do i want to do next where where i
want to go and everything kind of
stalled because of the pandemic and it
didn't for you obviously because you
just [ __ ] kept going for it but i i
really appreciate like
seeing what you're doing and
just i'm stoked for you man like that's
it there are so many people i know
like there's a lot
of people
in this space in this industry whatever
you want to call it that are
pretty [ __ ] fake and
uh i haven't ever gotten that vibe from
you like you're
you're about what you're doing and it
pisses a lot of people off i would say
right like that's not
is that a affair
maybe
unsealed yeah um oh in new york too i
guess i'm just like i'm not like very
friendly um i don't know maybe it's
because i'm asian and i'm not used to
talking
in the american way
uh and also maybe as because i have like
i don't know
chronic neck injury that makes me
miserable all the time oh [ __ ] i don't
know that
yeah i don't think it's a big deal
just guessing as to why i promotionally
and angry
all the time maybe it's my exploitation
at the hands of capitalism but uh i uh
yeah i mean i i think that i could do
open mics and not be such a dick but i
just chose to be a dick and to do a lot
of open likes i don't think
they correlate or maybe they do maybe
after doing a lot of open mics you just
don't
respect people as much anymore but
hopefully not yeah man
what's what's sort of next for you
though like
what
i mean you're doing kill tony now
is it
do you have any like sort of
trajectory you're looking to take that
to or
is it just riding the wave
i'd like to start featuring on the road
and then headlining
uh
working on
writing new jokes and having an hour
um maybe
do sketches continue to do internet
stuff
um yeah i mean
just
uh express myself in every way possible
i mean i like podcasting i like
i like acting when i can get
writing sketches i like you know doing
man on the street interviews and
i mean yeah i could do anything i i want
to yeah do a lot of things
but yeah
it's just like i'm so lazy that's the
only thing like i could write sketches
and star in
short films if i wanted to i just
can't motivate myself to do it but
you know at least i'm doing a stand up
it's been cool to watch you doing
everything you're doing and i appreciate
you coming on man thanks for having me
man yeah
well thanks everybody for listening if
you enjoyed this episode make sure to
share
this with a friend and rate and
subscribe to us wherever you get
podcasts
uh we're gonna leave you with jogging i
just make the ways i don't write them
i can hear the lyrics in my spirit as i
write them why you want to walk and talk
just like them
i can't get caught up in all the hype
and the excitement i just make the ways
i don't write them
i can hear the lyrics in my spirit as i
write them why you wanna walk and talk
just like them
you